[music]
I know what a beautiful
snowy wind children embrace tea a
blood pill strained with a grenade goals to go after
you you can already pick it up and our sand
Giray drank ships on its edge the smell of
fish waved this one
already taken away and you are mine you pressed
so I will come and fall in love
I know very well
[music]
does not smell like a thief and an apple
and a tassel Red stone Snay
get enough sleep land in the sea not with your hands
from Ukraine takeaways of strangers at the edge are carried out and the
testament of the reviterbor tetrabase I will
soon have a
name
I came up with for you I am a young Soldier
I know everything  words love I know
[music]
fine
[music] [
music] [
music]
party fine
[music]